okay again I'm sorry for the differences
in time I know that we had to adjust a
few things and hopefully by next session
everybody will be able to join and we
will record every session so if anyone
misses any of the sessions you'll be
able to access the recording and what
we'll do today is we'll just kind of
give an overview of the program talk
about the different online resources
that we've prepared for the program and
make sure that you can access everything
that we have I will also talk about the
first subject kind of going over the
basics of cancer biology and some of the
things that we will have to factor in as
we go into bioinformatics to make sure
that the bioinformatics methods and the
data that we analyze reflects the cancer
biology and the clinical manifestations
of cancer that we would like to study so
as you know precision medicine is
changing the way that we understand
diagnose and treat cancer and to
understand how this transformation is
happening we have to look to data
because a lot of these changes about the
understanding of the cancer biology and
about the ability to treat cancer more
effectively and more precisely is coming
from this high-throughput molecular data
that is coming from a variety of sources
including of course cancer patients but
also animal models designed specifically
to study aspects of cancer biology as
well as large-scale cell line
experiments where we can test different
types of reactions of cancer changes
throughout the process of
differentiation and throughout the
process of treatment obviously a lot of
those things cannot be consistently
studied in cancer patients and so cell
line experiments provide us with that
opportunity and so in this program what
we will try to explore is how the
various types of omics data can be
analyzed and integrated to understand
the basic biology associated with
different stages of cancer including the
first emergence of cancer and maybe
pre-emergence the risk of cancer onset
the development of tumors and the
outcomes and how we clinically can see
those manifestations and so we'll see
how these large-scale data sets that are
collected from the different research
projects and clinical trials really
provide us with an opportunity to better
understand this complex disease and
think about different ways where the
treatment and the the treatment can be
improved sorry I see the video pop up
here okay so for now again for those of
you that are joining please make sure
that your microphone is muted you can
also disable your video that will help
improve the quality of the video for
everyone okay so the program is going to
start today but will continue through
May 16th and during this time we will
learn about the different methods the
different data and how to apply analysis
of genomic and transcriptome data to the
study of the cancer biology our focus
will be on bio informatics method so we
will talk in detail about how different
methods are combined together in
pipelines what are those different
methods that we need to understand what
are the different alternatives to the
different stages of those pipelines and
then we will use different examples and
datasets taken from a variety of
oncology projects at the end of the
program we are encouraging you to apply
the learn skills to a dataset of your
own choice we will provide some curated
examples that you can pick from or you
can take any dataset any type of data
set that you will find online or maybe
use one of your own so that you can
understand how the methods that we've
learned about and the pipeline's that we
learn how to do really work in the
context of a project of your own and
during that time the project time we
will support your research to make sure
that you can process analyze and
interpret the data so it's about two
months of kind of learning the
theoretical aspects and then one month
of going through your own data set
obviously some data sets are larger and
will require more time so you can either
continue interacting with us after that
or you can decide to just kind of leave
it there
but we will support you throughout this
period of time starting today up until
May 16th the program sessions will be
conducted primarily by our team that
includes dr. Joseph Callahan Mohit
Mazumdar and Darko Marin they will cover
the different aspects of the program
topics that we've prepared and I will be
just there to kind of connect the
different pieces together and also to
make sure that the bio statistical
principles the kind of biology and
biochemistry and the computational
biology are all clear to everyone that
is participating in the program we will
also have online interaction like this
in online sessions where you can ask
questions and get quick responses to
some of your questions but also we have
forums and different places where you
can submit information about yourself
about your background about the project
that you're interested in and also get
feedback and response from one of our
team members you will also see emails
coming from a beeps of Biswas she will
be taking care of the session recordings
and making sure that you have access to
those that those will be posted on the
forums and also you will see assignments
the inside different lessons that we've
prepared those will be graded and
reviewed and also if you have any
questions or difficulties going through
the practical steps we will be able to
assist you with those so let's go over
some of these resources that we have for
the program
so that everyone can kind of get
oriented and knows where to find
everything that we will be using
throughout this program so the program
resources can all be found if you go to
the main site edu that T - bio that info
and click right here under events you
will be able to see bioinformatics for
precision oncology right here and so
that link points you to this page so
this page you will see if you're already
registered and you logged in so right
now you can see this is a screen where
the person has not logged in if you're
not logged in you will see register for
membership if you have logged in you
should be able to see all of the events
and courses that we will use to log in
you click on the corner logon button or
link and here you will be able to log in
okay so this is for those of you that
are registered already if you're not
registered you've probably received an
email that has a registration link and
there you can go through the steps of
the registration including filling out a
pre registration form and then getting a
confirmation email and using that link
inside that email to complete the
registration now after you have
registered you will see the list of
events that will be sessions like this
one online sessions but also you will be
able to navigate throughout this menu
specific to this program and in this
menu you will see that we have a forum
that I already talked about briefly and
we have this tab called courses and here
in this tab you will see the different
online courses that you can use on your
own time they're not timed but you have
a whole three months to kind of go
through these materials your membership
fourth the program will expire after
three months and then you can decide to
complete
all the material before the end of three
months or continue using an educational
research subscription to continue
learning and applying the different
tools that we discussed to different
data sets the program sessions like
today you will be able to see the
schedule of those and what topics are
covered and so you don't have to join
all of the sessions but the sessions
will include some basic introductory
materials they will include some
practical sessions when we go through
the different pipelines that we discuss
inside the lessons and they also focus
on different types of data for example
genomic data and transcriptomic data are
expanded in a collection of different
materials so we'll talk about some of
those things and how they relate to the
different aspects of cancer biology but
in the sessions you'll be able to
interact with one of our program
trainers to be able to answer or clarify
any of the questions or any other
assignments or get help with anything
but also we'll have some prepared
material to go over that will kind of
supplement some of the online materials
that we have I think it's going to be
worthwhile for you to go through some of
the materials online independently as
well because the time invested there
will help us make better use of session
time which is of course limited now in
the sessions we will talk about kind of
what we think are additional materials
to what's online and online you will see
a real detailed tutorial for different
aspects of the bioinformatics methods
you'll have a lot of links a lot of
terminology and we'll go through through
some of these elements today as well for
example we will go through the
transcriptomics collection so the core
series in this collection is a broad and
yet detailed overview of processing
statistical analysis machine learning
tools and single-cell data analysis
techniques inside the course too
we will in detail review the
bioinformatics methods and what is the
logic of using them expand on the
terminology that you need to know to
understand what the methods do and what
do they do with the data that is there
and also provide practical examples as
well as provide some quizzes for self
evaluation and Elton here is asking if
you can ask questions so I will have
specific points in the presentation
where I will pause for everybody to ask
any questions so let me get to those and
then feel free to ask them so I want to
first just kind of review some of the
technical elements so everybody
understands how these things are
connected together so for example you
can go to the syllabus tab under the
program and see the different sessions
and the different courses that are added
there and then in the course itself
you'll be able to see what the course
has in terms of its curriculum what the
topics that are covered and then once
you finish the course you'll be able to
see that you have finished it and you
will get a certificate or you can retake
the course again so those sessions are
really the sessions that we will have in
the program are really built around the
time frame that we think it will take to
complete some of these online materials
now if you are a member of the program
all of these courses are going to be
free and you can also continue using
them or retaking them for the duration
of the program which is about 3 months
now for example transcriptomics 1 you
can see that we will provide an overview
of the materials in a short video and
then you will see how inside the course
different elements of the review are
going to be expanded upon and so
whenever when you get into the course
you will get a series of lessons after
you complete each lesson you will see
that it turns into
green pea and inside the course you will
see that there's a control section here
on top and that control section actually
includes a lot of materials that you can
leverage as you go through so for
example it will have a course outline
you can search for different terms you
can go to the previous and next lessons
there's a forum with different comments
that you can add there if there are
small images that you would like to
magnify there's a little magnifying
glass thing you can also download the
materials as PDFs if you want to use
them offline I change the font size and
also close the lesson to go back to the
main course overview there are full PDFs
like I said that are included there and
you'll be able to download those PDFs
and use them offline
you can also track the progress and
always come back to where you left off
so you will see for example that you
have completed the course or you're 75%
into the course and then go through the
section where you left off you can also
see that this is going to be updated
every time you complete a lesson and you
will also be able to see glossary of
terms and the glossary of terms will
kind of go through the different topics
covered in each lesson and you will be
able to quickly find what those mean as
you hover over for example like this you
hover over that term and you will have a
little pop-up that comes up that
explains what a specific term means
there are also going to be practical
hands-on assignments and those practical
hands-on assignments will be graded in
the sense that you will get some kind of
point there's a point system that you
will discover that we utilized in this
process but you will get a response get
some feedback from one of our trainers
on the assignment that you submit and
that really helps you see whether you
understood the material and whether
you're able to
analysis the way that it was described
you will receive those by email or you
will also see notification on your
profile now those practical assignments
we can track your activity on the
educational portal and we can also track
your activity on the analysis platform
that we provide during this time so
that's why whenever you have for example
a pipeline that you've run or an
analysis result the site the assignment
will be designed in such a way that we
can easily go into the pipeline and see
what you did and check that you've done
the right thing or look at the analysis
result and kind of expect it to look
almost exactly like what we described so
that we can quickly get you the feedback
that you need to know whether the
assignment has been completed correctly
to submit an assignment you will be able
to attach files or describe your answer
in text and so that will help us make
sure that you have a question or you've
submitted something and there's
obviously resubmissions as well so this
really is designed in a way that we can
clearly see where H each person is in
the process of going through the
materials and doing the different
aspects of the practical application of
the material that is learned and we can
see that everyone understands what's
going on now all of this information is
collected under your profile so this is
an example profile here you can see that
the person we asked you all to obviously
complete your profile as much as
possible sometimes as you know we will
see you know different names when you
interact with us through the forum or
online in these sessions we want to be
able to understand who that person is so
it's very helpful if you can you know
put in your full name possibly even add
your picture or some information about
you so we know who you are you will see
under this profile all of your activity
so that activity willing
clewd quizzes that you take courses that
you start or finish pipelines that
you've run etc you will also see the
courses we can see or you can see the
courses that you are taking and where
you are in each course
sorry beep so there's also someone that
can't hear anything on or 7.x
maybe you can reply to that one and
other elements that you will find under
your profile you can also see your quiz
results and assignments beeps if you can
answer those questions yeah I'm doing
and also track your progress in terms of
your activity over the course of time
and so our hope through this activity is
to really help demonstrate how from
learning the theoretical aspects of the
different data types and topics that we
cover all the way to the practical
application you get a comprehensive view
of different bioinformatics methods and
examples where they are applied as a
result of this activity we will be able
to generate a certificate of completion
and that certificate of completion kind
of is based on the ability to do the
theoretical material to complete the
theoretical material and also go through
the practical pipelines that we expect
everyone to be able how to know how to
do and to be able to do and after the
after the program is over so to support
the practical materials as I said we
will use several different environments
where you can use bioinformatics methods
without coding or with coding so we will
use a lot of the introductory sessions
are going to be designed around the T by
moon for platform that really requires
no
coding and makes the connection between
the method and the logic for why to use
that method or what is the method
actually do without making it too
complicated and without making it too
technical then at the end as we go
through the more statistical methods we
will start looking at visualization of
data and be able to download some of the
code so that you can replicate some of
it in environments like the our studio
where you can use the our language to
launch several packages and kind of
expand on the different visualization
and analysis methods that we discussed
so to do that we have this platform the
platform combines many different tools
that are useful to analyze different
types of data and you can find that tool
on this link server dot t - bio-data
info so let me quickly go into that that
platform to show you how you can use it
they go to server that T - bio dot in
stone I'm just gonna make it a little
bit bigger for those of you that have
completed registration you should have
gotten an email with your login
information so you will have a username
which is an email and a password that
was emailed to you if you have not
received those please contact beeps on
even either now or by email to make sure
that you have that information so once
you are logged in you will have an
educational user license which means
that you can use specific data sets that
we provide to you specifically designed
for this program and after you complete
materials enough to get to about 2,000
points or over you will have access to
analyze some data set from the public
domain
we'll get to that point throughout the
session we'll kind of walk you through
that process
but just to kind of orient you here if
you are logged in you should be able to
see your profile right here this is
going to be a different password from
the one that you used on the educational
site after you get here you will see
this main areas of analysis which is
right here and here you have different
types of data that are described for
example next-generation sequencing mass
effect data structural biology data and
then different tools for data
integration and modeling we will
primarily focus on NGS data and also use
some of the sections from the data
mining and data Association parts right
here
here you have sections dedicated to
analysis of transcriptomic data genomics
and epigenetics so if you hover over
this little eye you will be able to see
the different sections and what they do
and we will also leverage the demo
pipelines so the demo pipelines are
really designed to introduce you to how
these different methods are connected
together and what is the logic behind
the analysis so if you click right here
this is only for people that do have
already access but if you do have
accessing you're logged in you'll be
able to click on this arrow and here you
have several examples for example the PD
X project is one of the project datasets
that we will discuss throughout the
program as well as the cell line project
so if you go in here you'll have the
pipeline environment open up and you can
only click on the highlighted button so
the highlighting buttons are going to be
the ones that are available for example
to start the pipeline you obviously can
only click on start and here you can
read a little bit about the logic of
this analysis for example what are the
different logical steps and how do they
translate to the different names that
you see in the interface
and what is their meaning right here on
this side you can also see the different
input and output files from each one of
your steps after you started you can see
that different options highlight those
options are based on the previous
selection so now I can for example do
the pre-processing and read about what
each step does also finding additional
information on the links provided below
then I can select the different options
for mapping for example all select high
sat - all right won't you like I decide
- yeah here we go and here you can see
what this method does okay something
happen here let me try again
traumatic PCR clean
- great and then I'll quantify the
levels of expression again you can read
about all of these different tools and
what they actually do and quickly after
I finish building this pipeline I will
be able to download the output files so
there's no waiting
there's no set of time this is really
designed for us to quickly go through
some of these materials and understand
what the meaning of the different
methods and how do they get us to an
expected output so the logic is going to
be described in the online sessions then
you will get more technical details in
the online courses and the courses are
going to be listed right here you can
see the different courses that are
included in the program and after you
complete those you will be able to see
the interpretations of what is the
result and we will discuss those in the
sessions as well so as you saw I built a
pipeline as I go through the pipeline I
get a description of what each method
does and when I complete I will get an
output that I can work with in any table
manipulation software for example I can
use it and are or I can use it in Excel
or OpenOffice or anything like that and
we will talk about what to do with this
data and what does it mean and that
might include visualization in some kind
of an analytical view of the data or it
might be a detailed view of all of the
different elements that are included in
the raw data that I had and now this is
the
for questions so Elton I know that you
had a question would you like to ask it
now I can you yes thank you was very
very nice presentation of the the
outside of the program history it sounds
a very very good program that one the
first question I had was on the public
domain data is there is there a plan to
to explore data coming for example from
the TCGA resources yes so at the end of
this session I will review future
sessions and we will cover three types
of data sources we will talk about cell
line data where we can find different
cell line data sets and an example of a
cell line data set we will talk about
animal models and where to find those
and we'll take an example from there and
then we'll also talk about patient data
so we'll talk about in Cancer Genome
Atlas and also other repositories where
we can find additional data about those
patients the second question I had was
on the technology it is going to cover
them specifically on the on the study of
the transcriptome it is going to be only
are we going to focus on your own
single-cell analysis or are we also
going to cover more to cover more
standard approaches for analyzing the
transcriptome using NGS technologies I'm
thinking for example for moral standard
approach is that there were because as
far as I understand the single cell is a
it's a trend and today but it's still
it's it's still very much experimental
method and it's no it's not very well
established it was only if all the
technologies was going to cover as well
beside the single cell analysis yes of
course we will spend a lot of time
talking about bulk RNA seek so how do
you use both RNA seek to do differential
gene expression how do we use it to look
in more detail at Aiza forms
different alternative splicing events
will talk about just standard gene
explanation and how to assemble the
different identify genes into pathways
and how to interpret those and then
we'll talk about the challenges that
come with single cell line as you
mentioned there are a lot of different
technologies a lot of those technologies
are still in development and a lot of
the results from those technologies
they're not very conclusive so there are
quite a number of challenges with single
cell but we will discuss those different
technologies and how to address the
different challenges or how they are
addressed computationally and the last
question I had was which we've got to
the integration of all this omics data
is there going to be while we're
progressing in each ohmic a focus on
what is the impact on each state of the
processing pipeline on the data
integration is it's going to be always
going to be rather a dedicated session
where we're going to address all the
issues with the data integration yes
great question so integration as you
think about mutations and genes and then
in those genes being expressed for
example there are several approaches to
integration one approach is through
annotation so if I know this gene and I
know that gene is for example enriched
with mutations and its expression
changes in some state then I can assume
that there must be a link between those
two events sometimes that link is not
obvious for example it can happen and
through epigenetic regulation instead of
mutations in those genes so we will talk
about those two approaches one is a more
straightforward and clear one annotation
and we'll do those in the context of
specific types of data but then we'll
also talk about analytical approaches to
detect associations between different
data features without necessarily
knowing that they are connected through
a database or some kind of annotated
source and that will be a separate
session that is not related to one
specific types of data okay all right
great
thank you for those great questions also
Dennis here had a question when is the
similar course on immunology becoming
available if any unfortunately we don't
have a course on immunology specifically
right away but what we do have is an
upcoming program on infectious diseases
where we will do similar to what we are
doing here talk about the different data
types and different examples of projects
including different endemic and epidemic
kind of known recent outbreaks like the
Ebola virus Zika virus flu and kovat 19
where we will talk about how to analyze
that data and apply it to the
understanding of the different genomic
variations in viral genomes as well as
the response from the host side right
and what are some of the immunology
aspects of infectious diseases so after
that hopefully we will start considering
other topics maybe including immunology
okay any other questions okay there are
no other
questions and you can continue to paste
those questions if you have any in the
notes here but I will just continue with
what we have planned for this session so
for today we prepared some introductory
materials that are designed to kind of
get us all in the same page so in this
section we will touch on ecology and the
challenges associated with big data and
cancer research a lot of it is driven by
the ability to generate highly detailed
data for example next-generation
sequencing data which provides us with
many features about a specific sample
that we have but also our ability to
collect many many samples about the same
condition and so some of you might
already be familiar with some of the
things that I will cover in the next few
slides but we wanted to review the
basics because I think they will quickly
bring anyone who is not familiar with
these things up to speed with the rest
of the group we will take some time to
discuss your questions if you have any
after this but also you're welcome to
pose you know additional kind of
insights that you think are valuable to
us as a group so let's start by talking
about the cancer biology at the cellular
and tissue levels and talked about the
role of DNA and RNA changes associated
with cancer risk progression and
outcomes so cancer is a complex
condition that manifests in changes to
cell regulation at many levels resulting
in abnormal growth that we observed on
the clinical level as a tumor tumors
consists of cells whose growth and
morphological characteristics are
markedly different from those of normal
cells criteria for malignancy include
increased cell proliferation loss of
differentiation infiltrative growth and
metastasis to other organs so you can
see here kind of the development from a
cell that has for example genetic
mutation or maybe a collection of
different mutations to hyperplasia
which is a growth that is occurring with
different types of cells inside to
distillation to in situ cancer which is
cancer localized in a specific tissue to
then invasive cancer cancer that starts
growing between different tissues and
different organs and so this progression
are the stages of tumor development so
malignant tumor develops to cross time
and the tumor develops as a result of
different mutations that are involved in
different types of tumors and the
different types of tumors can be
characterized by different mutations as
well as other different regulation
abnormality abnormalities that we will
talk about we don't know how many
mutations or which specific mutations
are required for a normal cell to become
a fully malignant cell but the number is
probably less than 10 right which is
pretty amazing given that we have over 3
billion nucleotides in the DNA the tumor
begins to develop when a cell
experiences immunization that makes the
cell more likely to divide than it
normally would and the altered cell and
his descendants grow and divide too
often which is a condition called
hyperplasia at some point one of these
cells experiences another mutation that
further increases in its tendency to
divide and the cell's descendants divide
excessively and look abnormal which is a
condition called dysplasia as the time
passes one of the cells experiences yet
another mutation and this cell and his
descendants are very abnormal in both
growth and appearance if the tumor that
has formed from these cells is still
contained within its tissue of origin it
is called in situ cancer in situ cancer
may remain contained indefinitely so
it's not a malignant tumor not a
malignant gravis if some cells
experience additional mutations that
allow the tumor to invade neighboring
tissues and shed cells into the blood or
lymph nodes the tumor is said to be
malignant
the escaped cells may establish new
tumors which are called metastasis at
other locations in the body so what are
some of those causes to make a cell to
become cancerous maybe about 30 years
ago only scientists could not offer a
coherent answer to this question they
knew that cancer arose from cells that
began to proliferate uncontrollably
within the body and they knew that
chemicals radiation and viruses would
trigger this change but exactly how it
happened was a mystery research across
the last three decades however has
revolutionized our understanding of
cancer in large part the success was
made possible by the development and
application of the techniques of
molecular biology techniques that
enabled researchers to probe and
describe features of individual cells in
ways that were unimaginable a century
ago today we know that cancer is a
disease of molecules and genes and we
even know how many of these molecules
and genes are involved in fact our
increasing understanding of these genes
is what is actually making possible the
development of exciting new strategies
to avoid stop and even correct the
changes that lead to cancer so what
we'll talk about briefly today are some
of those elements for example the
differences between normal and cancer
cells how those are linked to genomic
features and we'll talk about what those
genomic features are for example they
are genes that could be driving some
events or could be controlling those
events we'll talk about the role of the
tumor microenvironment that is the
environment that is around those
cancerous cells and the interaction
between the cells within the tumor and
the sender cells in those in that micro
environment as well as a major player in
that micro environment which is of
course the immune response the immune
system so what are some
those differences between cancer cells
and normal cells cancer cells differ
from normal cells in many ways that
allow them to grow out of control and
become invasive one important difference
is that cancer cells are less
specialized than normal kin as normal
cells so what it means is that normal
cells mature into very distinct cell
types with specific functions for
example a tissue is comprised of cells
that are pretty much similar to whatever
that tissue does but cancer cells do not
and that is one reason that unlike
normal cells cancer cells continue to
divide without stopping right so the
tissue forms by differentiating and then
controlling the growth so that the organ
functions in a specific way when we talk
about cancer cells they lose that
differentiation and they are not really
controlled by the signaling pathways
that the whole tissue uses to function
as a single element as an organ so for
example cancerous cells have large
variably shaped nuclei you can see right
here this is a normal cell and this is a
cancer cell you can see how the nucleus
is very big right so this is just some
of the external things that we see in
pathology chol images of tissues for
example you can see that inside a tumor
the cells are disorganized and they are
they have many dividing cells at the
same time so their division is not
controlled it's not organized and their
locations are not going to be very
organized you will see different
variations in types and shapes and you
will see lots of normal features for
example they're not going to be defined
shape they will have these abnormal
shapes in addition cancer cells are able
to ignore signals that normally tell
cells to stop dividing or that begin a
process known as programmed cell death
apoptosis which the body uses to get rid
of unneeded cells for example when a
cell ages and it reaches certain number
a number of divisions it is going to be
not as reliable its DNA might have
enough changes that it's unreliable for
continued division and typically that
would call that that would cause
apoptosis to happen and for that cell to
die
cancer cells may also be able to
influence normal cells molecules and
blood vessels that surround and feed a
tumor an area known as the micro
environment for instance cancer cells
can induce nearby normal cells to form
blood vessels that supply tumors with
oxygen and nutrients which they need to
grow these blood vessels also remove
waste products from tumors cancer cells
are often able to evade the immune
system so a network of organs tissues
and specialized cells that protects the
body from infections and in other
conditions or different types of immune
cells and although the immune system
normally removed damaged or abnormal
cells from the body some cancer cells
are able to hide from that immune system
tumors can also use the immune system to
stay alive and grow for example with the
help of certain immune system cells that
normally prevent a runaway immune
response cancer cells can actually keep
the immune system from killing cancer
cells now typically tumors are kind of
divided into cold or hot tumors by their
by the immune response hot tumors are
those that show signs of inflammation
meaning that the tumor has already been
infiltrated by T cells rushing to fight
the cancerous cells the tumor cells have
undergone many mutations that create new
antigens recognized by the T cells with
the presence of cancer-fighting t-cells
we know that the immune system has
already recognized the cancer and is
working to fight it and so had tumors
typically respond well to what's called
immunotherapy treatment and that is
typically used
checkpoint inhibitors the main idea
behind checkpoint inhibitors is using
antibodies to mobilize immobilize the
t-cell response during the attack on the
tumour t-cells become exhausted and
loses important functions needed to kill
tumor cells the exhaustion is brought on
by constant exposure to tumor antigens
and signaling through checkpoint
receptors the antibodies block signaling
through these two receptors to prevent
this loss of function now not all the
tumors are the same and so only a few
types are considered to be hot for
example melanoma bladder kidney had a
neck and non-small-cell lung cancer and
there are many different limiting
factors to the efficacy of
immunotherapies and for example some hot
tumors even though they are already hot
they are not going to be responsive to
treatment so that's another challenge
and combating these limitations research
a lot of research in immunotherapy is
focused on combining progressive
immunotherapy treatments with
traditional therapies like radiation and
chemotherapy so in the program we'll
actually talked a lot about you know
these biological processes but also the
different treatment options and what are
some of the considerations around
mutations or expression patterns that
can identify different abnormal or you
know undesirable effects that we should
consider what are the cold tumors non
immuno genic cold tumors have yet have
not been yet infiltrated with t-cells
which is a sign that the immune response
is not working for one reason or another
the lack of t-cells make it difficult to
provoke an immune response with
immunotherapy drugs these types of
tumors are mostly treated with
traditional cancer therapies most breast
cancers ovarian cancer prostate cancer
pancreatic cancer and glioblastoma are
typically cold tumors which poses a
problem for the widespread use of
immunotherapies the micro environment
surrounding the cold to
contains myeloid derive suppressor cells
MDS C and T regulatory cells T regs
which are known to dampen the immune
response and inhibit T cells trying to
move into the tumor so another aspect of
tumor development or cancer development
as a disease and the biggest concern of
course is metastasis so what we talked
about up until now is that specific
cells have mutations or changes in their
DNA they stop responding to the
different signaling pathways as a result
they interact with the environment
around them but they're also inside a
body and that body has many different
organs and once that tumor starts
spreading locally by moving into normal
tissue that is going to be triggering
the immune response however cancer can
also spread regionally to nearby lymph
nodes tissues or organs and it can
spread to distant parts of the body when
this happens it is called metastatic
cancer for many types of cancer it is
also called stage 4 cancer the process
by which cancer can cancer cells spread
to other parts of the body is called
metastasis when observed under a
microscope and tested in other ways
meant estatic cancer cells have features
like that of primary cancer and not like
the cells in the place where the cancer
is found this is how doctors can tell
that it is a cancer that has spread from
another part of the body right so for
example if it came from the breast and
metastasized to the bone it will have
those features of where it came from
and not of the bone metastatic cancer
has the same name as the primary cancer
for example breast cancer that spreads
to the lung is called metastatic breast
cancer not lung cancer and it is going
to be treated in a specific way for
example as stage 4 breast cancer not as
lung cancer
okay so any questions about some of
these different basic biology around
cancer and how these definitions will
help us identify what in the datasets
that we will be working with do they
represent right so we'll talk about the
different stages of cancer and we saw
how you know those different progression
stages of tumor development can help us
understand what those stages mean we
will talk about the features for example
the features are going to be
morphological features or omics features
for example genes mutations different
types of signaling pathways so it will
talk about pathways and then we'll try
to link those with what is clinically
observable so for example the rate of
progression or to talk about progression
between these different stages of cancer
development so are there any questions
about this so far or any comments
would like to add anything to what was
discussed
okay so the question is activating
mutations and oncogenes and in
activating mutations in tumor suppressor
genes leads to proliferation so yes we
will talk about what are the drivers of
some of these changes are so oncogenes
wouldn't be the genes that kind of drive
these processes and obviously those
genes can stop producing the right
effect and that effect would be for
example you know the progressions or the
different changes so a mutation might
change the way a gene is translated into
mRNA and protein eventually and then
there are different suppressing
mechanisms so mechanisms that control at
these different processes and so we will
talk about those and those are called
tumor suppressor genes so yes this is
correct and there are also other
considerations beyond mutations that we
will talk about that are related to the
regulation of these genes
you
okay so another question is what is the
exact role of kjerag cell in normal
people although to help cancer cells to
escape immune infiltration so the cells
that cancer cells they actually make use
of all of the you know normal cells that
are present in a body or in a tissue and
what we will see is that the difference
suppressing mechanisms that were
designed to stop we actually have a
project on this if you're interested in
this aspect
you know immune cells interact with
tumor with the cancer cells and the
cancer cells can cause the immune cells
to work in a different way so just like
they interact with other cells around
them and the micro environments they
will be able to cause those cells in the
micro environment to change their
function and do something that is
beneficial to the tumor growth into the
processes that it have has so they
essentially hijack the normal function
and that's an interesting process to
learn about and one of the ways that we
can learn about those is to look at for
example the different cells t-cells or
other cells and that's why I think you
know single cell techniques are so
powerful is you can actually separate
cells into different types and see kind
of what happens to them over time so and
not only by for example looking
exclusively at that cell but looking at
a tumor the way it develops as a system
right so for example you know previously
we could separate cells into different
types and kind of see what happens to
them individually but single cell
technologies allow us to look at the
system as a whole and know what each
different types of cell is doing or how
it is changing
we'll talk about these different types
of cells selves in the context of you
know the micro environment as a whole
and we will also talk about how we can
study them using different techniques I
think you know the conclusions from
there exactly you know what is a
function of a specific cell in the
normal tissue as it is compared to for
example a tumor tissue are those kinds
of discoveries that will make throughout
the program and I think we'll be able to
do those on the level of data right and
that's what's important is we'll be able
to look at the data coming from
different projects to see what happens
because there are many different ways
that they you know their role changes
based on the type of tumor based on the
type of model that we're studying right
cancer patient's or animals or whatever
okay yes and obviously this is an
interesting topic with different types
of datasets that are available so we'll
go through some of the topics and the
projects that we'll have in the future
in the next session actually we'll start
talking about those so we don't have a
lot of time left but let me quickly go
through some of the slides that we have
to kind of introduce what are the
different topics that will be covered
throughout the program
when we talk about bio informatics we
are going to be focused on data and
we'll talk about how the changes in DNA
the different genes the different
changes in mRNA transcription can be
detected using analytical methods as a
result we will learn to understand how
to identify important elements in data
and link them together by finding
associations in the data sets we will
also learn about the different aspects
of the basic and the translational
research in oncology where we can
combine patient derived cell lines
xenograft models in clinical trial data
that will offer a rich collection of
different types of datasets that will
inform our understanding of cancer
biology the understanding how diagnosis
can be changed by looking at the
molecular factors and how we can as a
result understand the different
treatment options for cancer in patients
so today we reviewed introductory
materials about oncology and the
challenges associated with big data in
cancer research you're probably a lot of
you are familiar with these things but
we wanted to review the basics because
we think that they will quickly bring
everyone who is not familiar up to speed
with the rest of the group in the next
session we'll start talking about
next-generation sequencing data what
this data can reveal about the
biological processes and the clinical
manifestations of cancer drivers tumor
development and the tumor
microenvironment and will speak about
the challenges of these big data sets
that are unstructured and have to be
processed before they can be analyzed
and annotated to yield insights into
cancer biology and we'll talk about the
significance of some of the steps that
can actually quickly change the ways
that we understand and interpret the
data that we have
so I'm not gonna pause here because we
are running out of time let us briefly
review the topics that we plan to cover
and where you can start finding the
relevant relevant materials to make
progress before the next session before
we meet again on March 12th
please start going through the
introduction of bioinformatics course
it's a really brief introductory course
you will find it under the main menu of
the edu that T - bio info website it
will provide an overview of bound for
Mattox and various domains like
healthcare defense and agriculture it
will also have a survey that we hope
that you can fill out for us to get more
familiar with your research background
and your objectives in this course we
will use this information to make sure
that the sessions are appropriately
designed to your level of your
background and bioinformatics and also
your background on ecology and hope to
help you advance with your goals and
objectives throughout these sessions so
next time when we meet we'll talk about
how the growth of high-throughput
sequencing in of cancer genomes and
transcriptomes has produced a big data
problem that precludes many cancer
biologists and oncologists from gleaning
knowledge from these data regarding the
nature of malignant processes and the
relationship between tumor genomic
profiles and treatment responses and I
think it's important for everyone to
learn about these data types and
understand either the logic of how to
efficiently process and analyze them or
practically to learn how to do it on
your own so that you can yourself do
these kinds of projects with a data set
of your own we'll start by first talking
about DNA variation like single
nucleotide polymorphisms and copy number
variation by looking at several NGS
genomic data like whole exome or whole
genome sequencing of tumor and normal
tissues these materials are covered in
our genomics series where we talk about
you know introductory materials about
what is
DNA what are the nucleotides how do
those changes occur and how do we detect
them and we'll also take a look at how
we can visualize this data after it has
been mapped on the reference genome and
then use that mapping to detect
significant changes that had happened in
DNA sequences over a course of several
different samples that we can combine or
just by looking from a single tumor
versus normal sample in a given tumor
and we will do that using different
reference genomes and paired tumor
normal samples we'll also spend time
turn looking at gene expression by
applying RNA seek analysis methods and
practicing some of those analysis steps
and the different pipelines will do a
lot of that using the T baiioon for
platform because the datasets are quite
large and so doing them on your computer
will require a lot of computational
resources that we don't necessarily
expect you to have at home and those
courses as I mentioned before are all
collected in this comprehensive
transcriptomics collection we'll start
by before that session will start by
transcriptomics one and throughout the
whole program you'll be able to go
through two three and four for example
like we did today we will try different
types of analysis pipelines and compare
different results to understand what
they can tell us and then what are the
critical steps in the pipeline to show
us the correct type of information we're
expecting to find from next-generation
sequencing data where we can only look
at expression of genes or look deeper at
the isoform the alternative splicing
events level or even at x dawn level and
how we can then use that information in
different ways to analyze the data and
find associations with phenotypes that
we're interested in we'll talk about
differential gene expression but also
machine learning methods that help us
deal with bigger data sets that have a
lot of unwanted technical variation but
also can provide us with a better
understanding of the complexity of the
different for example cancer subtypes or
variations
that are not clearly shown when we have
a very controlled environment and we
just want to compare two different types
of conditions
we'll use advanced methods like a nova
and factorial regression analysis and
that analysis will help us understand
not only the difference and what the
difference is but also how the different
factors in experimental design affect
the outcomes that we observe on the gene
expression level so we'll use that for
example to understand the different
roles of genes that are involved in the
tumor micro-environment function when we
compare the interaction between tumor
and micro environment expression levels
to understand how they compare and what
they can yield about the differences in
the different types of data that we
analyze then we'll turn to biological
interpretation and that will help us
understand how do we combine the
different elements that we find in the
data with annotation by known pathways
and known ontology z' of genes to kind
of link the gene expression levels to
the functionality that we can observe
we'll learn by doing what's called
pathway enrichment or gene set
enrichment analysis that will
demonstrate how enriched different
pathways are and how we can map them on
those signaling pathways that we know to
be important in cancer differentiation
and we'll use that as an example to talk
about the different genes and the
different pathways that are critical for
tumor development well then turn to
different data sources and databases and
we'll actually review how to find
different types of data how to find
different corresponding tumor types
between cell lines animal models and
patients and then also how to annotate
the different results of analysis that
we have from the mutations that are
associated with treatment or with
progression outcomes and discuss how
those have been established in the past
when we talk about the cancer genome
analyst we'll talk about patient cohorts
how do we actually
take published patient cohorts or select
from those patient cohorts the different
type of data that we would like to
analyze and combine those in a
meaningful way we'll also talk multi
onyx about multi-omics integration
during this session because the TCGA
provides a comprehensive overview of
multiple levels of onyx data about
different conditions we'll also talk
about mutations and interactions of
mutations as they have a role in the
response to different treatments and
then we will transition to project
design and proposals and on that stage
we expect everybody to be familiar
enough with the different steps of data
processing analysis and interpretation
to be able to consider a project of your
own once I and there we will talk about
how we can use different examples that
we have provided for example the breast
cancer example of the liver cancer
example and how you can introduce some
variation to those data sets that have
already been provided to you or you will
be free to choose a data set of your own
and kind of design the analysis before
you conduct the analysis and we'll talk
about the different questions about the
data to make sure that we can maximize
the value of a proposed project and help
streamline the analysis process so that
it is done more quickly and efficiently
to show first of all exploratory results
that could be evaluated for their real
kind of like value once the project is
completed so how do you quickly go from
having a data set to having it in such a
way that you can rapidly ask questions
about the data set to see whether it's
going to answer some question that you
might have but also talk about how you
can maximize that value by
incorporating other datasets and other
databases of known published results
some of the examples we'll talk about in
our next session what those examples are
and how those examples are relevant to
the objectives of bioinformatics and
precision oncology and talk about the
different collected data sets and how
you can navigate those data sets to find
something that is relevant to maybe a
question that you might have for your
own project
so again we went a little bit over time
with the session but I hope that it was
informative and again if you have not
received any of the information to
access the materials that we've
discussed here and to find all of the
different elements to the program please
reach out to us if you have any
questions about the program itself you
know the program will provide you with a
certificate of completion at the end of
the program and will provide you with
some hands-on assistance where you will
be able to work on your own data set so
I did want to mention that and at the
end of the session of course if you have
any questions about the program itself
or how it will be conducted I can answer
those now
you
you
so I have a question tonight yes go
ahead I'm very interested only on the
lh8 IHC cohort from the TCGA the liver
cancer cohort you mentioned on the other
side and I was wondering are you
planning or can we maybe suggest during
this during the expiration of this
cohort other datasets that can become
potentially combined with this cohort to
have a sort of meta-analysis yeah this
is a great example yeah I think that
would be great we want to make sure that
we go through some introductory sessions
that will describe the methods and the
different data features that we expect
to find then we'll introduce that
dataset to talk about you know what is
found there and how you find it and then
yes you can you will actually have a
forum where you can fill out what you
are interested in and that will help us
kind of streamline the process and help
everyone in the group you know to make
similar ideas more clear as they think
about the projects that they have cool
Thanks yep thank you and thanks Joe
posted here if you have any questions
between now and in our next session you
can post them on the forum and there's a
link to the forum so you can post your
questions there that will help us
prepare and answer to your questions
before the next session and also help us
you know set up a time one-on-one if
that's needed to discuss more in depth
question that might or might not be
related to what we want to do as a group
so again thank you everyone for joining
today we will send you an email about
the video the recording of this session
and obviously you can you start using
some of the resources that we have
before our next session we encourage you
to go through introduction to
bioinformatics at least to complete that
form in the first lesson where you'll be
able to tell us a little bit
about yourself and we want to learn
about what your background is and what
you're interested in interested in and
what your motivation is so please do
that
and we are excited to see you again in
our next session
does anyone else want to add anything to
that
Joe Darko or Mohit
or beep sir
I don't have anything for now other than
if you have any questions please post
them on the forum and I will do my best
to have those answers before the next
session great no further questions
Lia fantastic session thank you and also
if anyone has any questions regarding
the data or data science they can send
to any any of us and we'll be happy to
answer
Thank You Nicole welcome okay Mohini did
you want to add anything to that
okay all right well great thank you
and yes Raphael did you want to ask
something
what datasets so yeah we talked in
detail about the datasets we will use
datasets from NCBI that talk about
cancer cell lines and patient-derived
xenograft models from mouse models of
different tumors and we will talk about
the genome cancer atlas yes these are
going to be next generation sequencing
datasets that combine different samples
by tumor and normal contrasts as well as
different stage contrasts and we'll talk
about how to analyze those and if you
know we'll be happy to send you more
results we're just wrapping up here so
we'll probably try to reach out to you
by email so if you can leave your email
here we'll make sure to send you that
information
hi everyone I would just want to add
this that many of you are trying to
access the courses so they are all going
to be free for you and we'll be adding
everybody's email ids to the
organization page by today so you should
be able to access all the courses that
are there and I'll be emailing everybody
with the course links that you can take
and all those that are available please
let us know if you have been able to log
into the server platform and also to the
educational platform and do the courses
just let me know if you have any trouble
there so that is all and thank you for
attending Thank You Ilya all right thank
you very much big shot we look forward
to seeing you again next time and Rafael
we will definitely reach out to you by
an email with additional information on
the datasets alright until next time
you